fed up ottawa residents fill several
intersections trying to block protest
vehicles headed downtown the almost
incomprehensible failure of leadership
in this city took a bunch of random
citizens being annoyed to actually stop
trucks and not police
this video shows two vehicles that kept
rolling as people got in front of them
he hit me i was so
shocked that somebody would do that
i know i was standing in the road and
that's not allowed but they've been
blocking streets for two weeks now
late sunday a potential breakthrough
ottawa's mayor released letters showing
convoy leadership agreed to move out of
residential zones and stick to
parliament hill police pegged the crowd
at 4 000 saturday here at the war
memorial the fencing that surrounded the
site remains down saturday a group of
protesters many who appeared to be
veterans or wearing medals camouflage or
berets took down that fencing the office
of the minister of public services and
procurement says pspc put up the
original fencing and they planned to
replace it as soon as they're told it's
safe to do so but as of sunday no
offense we'll put a man on it next one
this is all you guys
many concerned about hands-off policing
including handing off responsibility for
guarding the memorial to the protesters
and this time lapse video shows there
wasn't always someone at the war
memorial overnight concerned too about
the views of some of those involved
they're trying to say that the guys are
you know they were waving it's a nazi
salute
that's so desperate and insane
and um and the police didn't do anything
because they know it's ridiculous they
know themselves it's ridiculous in this
video veteran jeremy mckenzie talks
about the importance of having free
access to the site he was recently
arrested for firearms violations in nova
scotia the canadian anti-hate network
flags him for among other things a live
stream about burning parliament down and
his phrase gun or rope for how to deal
with those ideologically opposed i think
we all have to recognize that you know
the harm that is being caused by these
individuals and it's not about people's
frustration with the pandemic a comment
from bill blair that directly
contradicts every person we've spoken to
on ottawa streets we're spreading love
because we are the focus of the world
right now ottawa freedom
protesters maintain they're here
peacefully upset with coveted mandates
abigail b minute global news ottawa